I'm alone, be I won't be soon In New York City, when I see you.
当我见到你时，我独自一人，但我不会很快在纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Hello, hello and welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的另一集。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Josh!
乔希！
Hey, Craig!
嘿，克雷格！
I don't know.
我不知道。
I want to try something else.
我想尝试别的东西。
Just your name.
只是你的名字。
Josh, you know, you fall into a rut, you go, I'm here as ever with my friend, you're just like, damn, this is the same thing every time.
乔什，你知道，你陷入了墨守成规，你走了，我和我的朋友一样在这里，你就像，该死的，每次都是同样的事情。
So I'm glad I'm glad we mixed it up.
所以我很高兴我们把它混合在一起。
Yeah, we're mixed.
是啊，我们是混血儿。
This is great.
这太棒了。
Well, this is a great episode to mix it up with because this is all, this is a, we were talking about columns two episodes ago, which was a little more straightforward linear.
嗯，这是一个很好的混合起来的剧集，因为这就是全部，这是一个，我们在两集前讨论过专栏，这是更简单的线性。
And this is like, we're talking about Lucky Penny today.
就像我们今天谈论的幸运便士一样。
This is a podcast, by the way, we talk about how I met your mother, which is a TV show that I start in skyped over as Ted Mosby and and Craig co-created the show with his buddy and my buddy Carter Baze and we're making our way through, we're deep into episode, sorry season two.
顺便说一下，这是一个播客，我们谈论的是我是如何认识你母亲的，这是一个电视节目，我在 Skype 上开始播放，泰德·莫斯比和克雷格与他的好友和我的好友卡特·贝兹共同创作了该节目，我们正在努力完成，我们正在深入剧集，对不起第二季。
This is an episode called Lucky Penny, which is a great episode, really funny.
这是一集叫Lucky Penny，非常棒的一集，真的很有趣。
I feel like a lot of the virtues and kind of bravura storytelling strokes of that, how I made your mother's best at or really on display here.
我觉得它有很多优点和勇敢的讲故事的笔触，我如何让你母亲最擅长或真正在这里展示。
Yeah, I will give Carter a ton of credit.
是的，我会给卡特很大的信任。
This is very much a Carter Bayes, the brilliant Carter Bayes, a baby of his, just the shape of going backwards in time to find out where it all started.
这很像卡特·贝叶斯，才华横溢的卡特·贝叶斯，他的孩子，只是时间倒流以找出一切开始的地方的形状。
It's kind of the whole series in miniatures in this episode.
这一集有点像整个系列的缩影。
I love episodes like this where the whole episode, it's like the mosquito in amber containing the dinosaur DNA or there's just, the whole show is in episodes like this and it's a mystery, whose fault is it Ted is in this situation.
我喜欢这样的剧集，整个剧集就像琥珀里的蚊子，含有恐龙 DNA，或者只是，整个节目都在这样的剧集中，这是一个谜，泰德陷入这种情况是谁的错。
How far back can you trace it?
你能追溯到多远之前？
It's another mini mystery within the larger mystery of the series.
这是该系列更大谜团中的另一个小谜团。
I really like that about this.
我真的很喜欢这一点。
It is a good episode.
这是一个很好的插曲。
And also another encoded thing is, I believe, Ted's daughter is named Penny.
我相信，另一个编码的事情是，特德的女儿名叫佩妮。
Isn't that right?
是不是这样？
Yeah.
是的。
Which we didn't know at the time we did this.
我们当时不知道这一点。
We added that later.
我们后来添加了这一点。
This is the seed planted that will grow into that.
这是种下的种子，它将长成那样。
Yeah.
是的。
And just another, I know, you know, Ted Mosby, I often say, well, he's not real, but let's just call him real.
还有一个，我知道，你知道，特德·莫斯比，我经常说，好吧，他不是真实的，但我们就称他真实吧。
Let's call him some sort of archetype avatar that's floating out there in the cosmos.
让我们称他为某种漂浮在宇宙中的原型化身。
And I just want to say, Ted, I'm so sorry they discontinued the pennies, the US mints.
我只想说，特德，我很抱歉他们停止发行美国铸币硬币。
I'm sure this was a hard day for him.
我确信这对他来说是艰难的一天。
I let it pass without much commemoration personally, but I know that Ted probably felt the sting of that.
我个人并没有太多纪念就让它过去了，但我知道特德可能感受到了这种刺痛。
I forget if we were recording or we talked about this separately.
我忘记了我们是在录音还是单独讨论过这个问题。
When did we say this on the pod already?
我们什么时候在 Pod 上说过这句话了？
Once we did, we did, but it's very, it's very much.
一旦我们这样做了，我们就这样做了，但这是非常非常多的。
It's worth really, it really moves me the idea that you thought of that because I saw that new story and sort of didn't think twice.
这真的很值得，它真的让我感动，你想到了这一点，因为我看到了那个新故事，并且没有三思而后行。
But you as the guy that brought Ted to life in your body, you were Ted.
但你作为让泰德在你体内复活的人，你就是泰德。
You inhabited that character.
你就扮演了那个角色。
You, you felt, you felt it emotionally.
你，你感觉到，你在情感上感受到了。
You felt it in the cosmos that Ted, wherever he exists.
无论泰德存在于何处，你都能在宇宙中感受到他。
Now it is, he's not happy.
现在这样了，他不高兴了。
He's just sad about it, he lit a candle for the dearly departed U.S. penny.
他只是对此感到难过，他为那枚已逝去的美国便士点燃了蜡烛。
Yeah, he did.
是的，他做到了。
He definitely lit a candle.
他确实点燃了一支蜡烛。
Actually, from the Facebook group from Mahalah, she asks, do you ever think about the fact that Lucky Penny kind of sounds like Luke and Penny?
事实上，她在 Mahalah 的 Facebook 群组中问道，你有没有想过 Lucky Penny 听起来有点像 Luke 和 Penny？
Oh, boy.
哦，男孩。
Great observation.
很棒的观察力。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah, that's a great observation, Luke and Penny.
是的，这是一个很好的观察，卢克和佩妮。
I mean, yeah, we didn't know it yet, but the seeds are planted here.
我的意思是，是的，我们还不知道，但种子已经种在这里了。
Yeah, for sure.
是的，当然。
That's awesome.
太棒了。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Alec, tell us when when did this episode air?
Alec，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出？
Originally, February 12th, 2007, written by, I want to say Jamie Ronheimer.
最初是 2007 年 2 月 12 日，作者是 Jamie Ronheimer。
I think so.
我想是的。
Can you look it up to Delver?
你能查一下Delver吗？
Yeah, I want to say lots of things, Alec.
是的，我想说很多话，亚历克。
I don't just say them.
我不只是说说而已。
Yeah, wait, it's right in front of me here.
是的，等等，它就在我面前。
Here it is.
这里是。
No, I don't know.
不，我不知道。
Yes, Jamie, Jamie Ronheimer, very funny dude, wrote this one, I, yeah, this is a great one.
是的，杰米，杰米·罗海默，非常有趣的家伙，写了这篇文章，我，是的，这是一篇很棒的文章。
By the way, Penny, but now when we see an episode about a penny, we can say old tech.
顺便说一句，佩妮，但现在当我们看到有关一便士的剧集时，我们可以说旧技术。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Well, speaking of, there is an old tech thing that becomes like an updated tech when they're tracking the marathon, tracking the marathon, which of course is find your friends, which is like, yeah, Rebecca was like, ooh, that's old.
好吧，说到这里，有一种古老的技术，当他们追踪马拉松时，它会变得像更新的技术，当然是​​找到你的朋友，就像，是的，丽贝卡就像，哦，那是旧的。
That's outdated.
那已经过时了。
That would just be your phone now.
现在那只是你的手机。
Yeah, but there's also, but Barney making a phone call from the train, which at the time, there is no chance you could have done, but now totally could do.
是的，但还有，但巴尼在火车上打电话，当时你不可能做到这一点，但现在完全可以做到。
Yeah.
是的。
Wait, that wasn't on train, but like at the stop to the station, you couldn't get a signal back then?
等等，那不是在火车上，但就像在车站一样，当时你收不到信号？
Maybe.
或许。
I'm going to say it's a maybe.
我想说这是一个可能。
I don't think it was a definite.
我不认为这是一个确定的。
Well, this is like, this is literally, this is actually a very, an amazing inflection point because I think 2007 when this episode aired was the release of the iPhone, right?
嗯，这就像，这实际上是一个非常非常惊人的转折点，因为我认为 2007 年这一集播出时是 iPhone 的发布，对吧？
are correct.
是正确的。
2007, like, you know, Jonathan Hight and all these people are marking that as a perilous and momentous kind of turn in human history.
2007 年，乔纳森·海特 (Jonathan Hight) 和所有这些人都将其标记为人类历史上危险而重大的转折。
Yeah, the end of a certain era.
是的，某个时代的结束。
Yeah, like we were on the air.
是的，就像我们在广播中一样。
And, you know, I think we've talked about this, but like I might have had a flip phone when I got to how I met your mother, and then the trio, we all had trios.
而且，你知道，我想我们已经讨论过这个问题，但就像我可能有一部翻盖手机一样，当我谈到我如何认识你母亲时，然后是三人组，我们都有三人组。
The trio, we all got the trio.
三人组，我们都得到了三人组。
With the little pen stick, the little stick.
用小笔棒，小棒。
Oh yeah, that's right, the little stylist.
哦对了，就是那个小造型师。
thing?
事物？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
The stylist, the stick.
造型师，棒子。
I was the last person to get an iPhone and I remember Dave Baker kind of helping me with it and kind of like, it was a little bit like you're going under.
我是最后一个拿到 iPhone 的人，我记得戴夫·贝克 (Dave Baker) 帮助了我，有点像你快要破产了。
Like you're about to go under and be some zoom.
就好像你即将沉入水中并进行变焦。
It's a matrix moment.
这是一个矩阵时刻。
It's like, yeah.
就像是的。
It's a moment I took very casually that I look back on now and think, huh, that really ruined my life.
那是我非常随意地度过的一个时刻，现在回想起来，我想，呵呵，那真的毁了我的生活。
I wish I could go back with some more guardrails.
我希望我能带更多的护栏回去。
But anyway, yeah, that that made me laugh, old tech, tracking, tracking thing.
但无论如何，是的，这让我笑了，老技术，跟踪，跟踪的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
There was also another old ref, which I like, are we sticking with old ref?
还有另一个我喜欢的旧裁判，我们是否坚持使用旧裁判？
Let's stick with old ref.
让我们继续使用旧参考。
I think where you were, it's our twist on the office lady's old tech.
我想你在哪里，这是我们对办公室女士的旧技术的改造。
Yeah, let's commit.
是的，我们承诺吧。
Let's commit.
让我们承诺吧。
What was it like he tried to bet me that it hungry like the wolf was sung by men at work?
他试图跟我打赌，工作时的男人会唱《饥饿如狼》，这是什么感觉？
And then he tried to get them to record it.
然后他试图让他们记录下来。
He tried to record it.
他试图记录下来。
Yeah, that one, you'd have to look up if you're under about 45 or so, right?
是的，那个，如果你45岁左右，你就得查一查，对吧？
You'd have to the kids today.
今天你得照顾孩子们。
But if you were a kid, when we were kids, 100%, that's like a classic hardy musical reference.
但如果你还是个孩子，当我们还是个孩子的时候，100%，这就像经典的哈迪音乐参考。
You know, both bands, you know, multiple hits by both bands.
你知道，两个乐队，你知道，两个乐队都取得了多次成功。
You can remember the videos of each of them on MTV.
你可以记住他们每个人在 MTV 上的视频。
Yeah.
是的。
Look, we have some of those.
看，我们有一些。
It can't all be timeless, folks.
伙计们，这不可能都是永恒的。
It can't all be timeless.
它不可能都是永恒的。
We were off our moment.
我们已经不在状态了。
Yeah.
是的。
So Craig, just take us through a little bit of what this episode is and where it came from.
克雷格，请带我们了解一下这一集的内容以及它的来源。
Like where did the spring from, the writer's room?
就像春天从哪里来的，作家的房间？
Yeah, I mean, I think we wanted to tell a story in reverse, the way that the series is kind of in reverse in certain ways, or at least a big go back from the year 2030.
是的，我的意思是，我认为我们想讲述一个相反的故事，该系列在某些方面有点相反，或者至少是从 2030 年开始的一个大倒退。
And that idea that when something goes wrong in your life, you try to be this forensic detective and go, how, what do I trace this back to?
当你的生活中出现问题时，你会尝试成为一名法医侦探，然后去，如何，我可以追溯到什么？
What can I blame this on?
我能把这归咎于什么呢？
And it's a series of Ted thinking, Ted and Robin, thinking they've found the reason there in this terrible situation of Ted being about to miss a flight to a huge potential career opportunity in Chicago.
这是泰德的一系列思考，泰德和罗宾，认为他们已经找到了泰德即将错过飞往芝加哥的航班的可怕情况的原因。
Um, and the idea that you're sitting there pretending you had control over life.
嗯，还有你坐在那里假装你能掌控生活的想法。
And you're trying to, you're trying to do the detective work of like, this is where it all happened.
你正在尝试，你正在尝试做侦探工作，就像这就是一切发生的地方。
This is why it happened.
这就是它发生的原因。
And I think that's a very Ted Mosby way of thinking that's part of why it's a great episode.
我认为这是一种非常泰德·莫斯比的思维方式，这也是为什么这是一集精彩的部分原因。
And it is a very fun storytelling structure to just go backwards, backwards, backwards, backwards and see how all of those little stories overlap and connect and one informs the other.
这是一种非常有趣的讲故事结构，只需向后、向后、向后、向后，看看所有这些小故事如何重叠和连接，一个故事如何通知另一个故事。
And in the end Ted realizes he goes so far back in this attempt that he realizes he himself is he kicked off the whole chain of events, so.
最后，特德意识到他在这次尝试中走得太远了，他意识到他自己是他拉开了整个事件链的序幕，所以。
Right.
正确的。
Well, again, that's the kind of encapsulation nutshell meta kind of stroke in this episode, which is, I mean, I've done this with many things in my life.
好吧，再说一遍，这就是本集中的那种封装元中风，我的意思是，我在生活中的很多事情上都做到了这一点。
Like if I hadn't met this person, they brought me here and I met so-and-so, I've done that with how I met my wife and all this stuff.
就像如果我没有遇到这个人一样，他们把我带到这里，我遇到了某某，我在遇到我的妻子和所有这些事情时就做到了这一点。
But like, if you really get granular and cosmic about it, you're like, well, it started with the Big Bang.
但是，如果你真正了解它的颗粒度和宇宙性，你就会觉得，好吧，它是从大爆炸开始的。
Like, it all started with the Big Bang.
就像，这一切都是从大爆炸开始的。
And maybe before, what caused the Big Bang, who knows?
也许之前，是什么导致了大爆炸，谁知道呢？
There's no end to that game.
这场比赛没有结束。
That's also, that was Ted.
那也是，那是特德。
That was Ted.
那是特德。
Yeah, he's the reason we all exist, yeah.
是的，他是我们存在的理由，是的。
Before it was darkness, and then Ted had media.
天黑之前，特德就有了媒体。
Talk about an architect.
谈论建筑师。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, I mean, it's a fun kind of sliding doors game to play.
是的，我的意思是，这是一种有趣的滑动门游戏。
Because it's true, like, you know, you're lying.
因为这是真的，就像，你知道，你在撒谎。
They're literally sliding doors in the episode.
在这一集中，它们实际上是滑动门。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
是的，是的，完全正确。
But your life changes in what seemingly casual moments reveal themselves to be very consequential.
但是，你的生活会在看似偶然的时刻发生变化，而这些时刻却显示出非常重要的意义。
Yeah.
是的。
And the ending of this episode is very pointed and I know here we are telling the episode backwards starting at the end, but I really like that it fits the form.
这一集的结局非常尖锐，我知道我们在这里从结尾开始向后讲述这一集，但我真的很喜欢它符合形式。
I really like the future narrator having the last word in this episode of you can do all All the detective work you want, 2007, Ted, but I, 2030, Ted, know that it was a great thing that you missed that flight because if you had you taken that flight, you might live in Chicago, you wouldn't be telling the story to those two kids because you wouldn't have met the mother.
我真的很喜欢未来的叙述者在这一集中的最后一句话，你可以做你想做的所有侦探工作，2007年，特德，但我，2030年，特德，知道你错过那趟航班是一件很棒的事情，因为如果你乘坐那趟航班，你可能住在芝加哥，你就不会向那两个孩子讲述这个故事，因为你不会见到母亲。
You wouldn't have those kids.
你不会有那些孩子。
That's a very cool, again, a Carta Bay is like very cool, big idea, big philosophical idea there.
这是一个非常酷的想法，Carta Bay 是一个非常酷的伟大想法，伟大的哲学思想。
And it's an, it's only an idea that a person who has enough sample size of life can put forward.
这只是一个拥有足够生活样本量的人可以提出的想法。
Yeah, like you I don't remember in high school going well if this hadn't happened that wouldn't have happened like I wasn't thinking And I didn't have enough life to see the kind of pattern that you know when people like I mean, I think there's something about there's a there's a big Peptalk at the center and the heart of how I met your mother which is it's all working out in some fascinating way and it's on the universes on your side and your struggles are your teachers and you are being led somewhere by a benevolent hand and when it looks darkest you're you know what I mean like there's they're they're they're quite spiritually sound lessons at the heart of it that's why people keep watching it.
是的，像你一样，我不记得在高中时会过得怎么样，如果这件事没有发生的话，就不会像我想的那样发生，而且我没有足够的生活来看到你所知道的那种模式，当人们像我的意思是，我认为有一些东西，在中心有一个很大的鼓舞人心的东西，在我如何遇见你母亲的核心，这一切都以某种迷人的方式进行，它在你身边的宇宙中，你的斗争是你的老师，你被一只仁慈的手引导到某个地方，当它看起来最黑暗的时候，你知道我的意思，就像它们是它们的核心一样，它们是相当精神上健全的课程，这就是为什么人们一直在观看它。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City will be right back.
我今天写信给你，是为了在纽约给你唱歌，很快就会回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
This detective work of who got us here.
这部关于谁让我们来到这里的侦探工作。
We start in the present and we go backwards and backwards and backwards and backwards.
我们从现在开始，然后倒退、倒退、倒退、倒退。
It is a thinking man's episode.
这是一个有思想的人的插曲。
It is a real thinker.
这是一个真正的思想家。
And I was excited watching it.
我很兴奋地看着它。
I was excited every time they were Ted and Robin in the then present in the 2007 present, realize, wait, no, the story goes back further.
每当他们在 2007 年的现在中扮演 Ted 和 Robin 时，我都很兴奋，意识到，等等，不，故事可以追溯到更远的地方。
I was so on edge of my seat to see that next installment.
我迫不及待地想看下一期。
It's such a great structure because it's like, wait, they're gonna back it up even further.
这是一个非常棒的结构，因为它就像，等等，他们会进一步支持它。
What happened?
发生了什么？
Who really caused this problem?
到底是谁造成了这个问题呢？
And it also allows everyone to be in the A story.
它还可以让每个人都参与到A故事中。
The whole gang is in the A story.
整个团伙都在A故事中。
That's it.
就是这样。
It is interesting you drew comparison to columns, which is again, two episodes prior to this.
有趣的是，你与专栏进行了比较，这又是在此之前的两集。
We were talking about how that was like A story, B story.
我们正在谈论这就像A故事，B故事。
They didn't connect that much.
他们没有那么多联系。
And we had a really fucking hard time with that one.
我们在这个问题上度过了一段非常艰难的时光。
We just couldn't get it to quite sing in the way they wanted to.
我们只是无法让它按照他们想要的方式唱歌。
When you have an episode like that, it just has to have a lot of funny shit in it.
当你有这样的一集时，里面一定有很多有趣的事情。
And kids, it's hard to write funny shit.
孩子们，写出有趣的东西很难。
You're way better off.
你的情况好多了。
You're way better off if you have a story structure that is like suspenseful and you have a series of reveals and twists and turns like that is much more our strength as one has it.
如果你有一个悬疑的故事结构，并且有一系列的揭露和曲折，那么你的情况会更好，这更像是我们的优势。
There's like an episode like columns or was cock-a-mouse in the matchmaker episode?
是不是有类似专栏的一集，或者是媒人一集里的鸡鼠游戏？
Was that the same episode?
这是同一集吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So there's certain B stories that I feel like, and I don't mean this as a criticism of the Ryerusum.
所以我觉得有些 B 故事，我并不是说这是对 Ryerusum 的批评。
I can see them on the dry erase board.
我可以在干擦板上看到它们。
That's funny ideas that you're like, well, I guess I could go there.
你的想法很有趣，好吧，我想我可以去那里。
That could be the B story.
这可能是B故事。
And you almost swap it, you just drop it in.
而且你几乎要交换它，你就把它扔进去。
And that's a lot of other sitcoms do it that way.
很多其他情景喜剧都是这样做的。
It's like, these things can go together, there's no harm in combining them.
就好像，这些东西可以放在一起，把它们组合起来没有坏处。
But I think we are at our best when they have to go together.
但我认为，当他们必须齐心协力时，我们才能达到最佳状态。
This episode, Lucky Penny is like a jenga.
这一集，Lucky Penny 就像叠叠乐。
It is.
这是。
Nothing can be removed.
没有什么可以删除。
It's all perfectly placed there.
一切都完美地放置在那里。
And I think that's very satisfying narratively to walk.
我认为步行叙事非常令人满意。
It's very satisfying.
这是非常令人满意的。
And when you see one story walk into the end of one story, catch back up to the beginning of another.
当你看到一个故事进入一个故事的结尾时，请回到另一个故事的开头。
Like when Ted and Robin walk in eating those hot dogs that the pennies dollar 50 value about, and they walk into the wedding, you know, into Lily and Robin, you know, Lily, No, they walk into realizing there's a wedding dress sale, which of course kicks off eventually, Lily doing that.
就像当泰德和罗宾走进去吃那些价值 50 便士的热狗时，他们走进婚礼，你知道，走进莉莉和罗宾，你知道，莉莉，不，他们走进去意识到有一场婚纱促销，当然最终开始了，莉莉这样做了。
We have to stay up all night.
我们必须整晚不睡觉。
I love how those fit together.
我喜欢它们如何组合在一起。
I love it.
我喜欢它。
I also love episodes.
我也喜欢剧集。
These are a lot of the mystery episodes start this way.
很多神秘事件都是这样开始的。
They start with running panic, like brunch started, kind of like just weird and like almost with like an act of violence, like the, the traiping of the episode, the one that starred Alec Lev, but running.
他们一开始就惊慌失措，就像早午餐开始一样，有点奇怪，几乎就像一种暴力行为，就像那集由亚历克·列夫主演的那一集，但他们跑了。
That's the thing.
就是这样。
What?
什么？
when they were running.
当他们跑步的时候。
Alex just woke up again.
亚历克斯刚刚再次醒来。
Didn't it start with Lily and Marshall running racing?
不是从莉莉和马歇尔赛跑开始的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You know, there's something, Alec running and race.
你知道，有一些东西，亚历克跑步和比赛。
And Alec and his beloved fiance running, but there's something about those episodes that start with that high energy.
亚历克和他深爱的未婚夫正在奔跑，但这些剧集的开头都充满了能量。
And it also, I don't know, it's like a movie that opens at a car chase.
而且，我不知道，这就像一部以汽车追逐开始的电影。
It was like, what is going on?
就像，发生了什么事？
You're immediately gripped.
你立刻就被抓住了。
In media rests, right?
在媒体休息中，对吧？
That's the first, that's the old school storytelling going back to the grease.
这是第一个，这是老派的讲故事方式，回到了油脂。
But like, yeah, Josh, you know what I'm thinking about when you say that too in this one, you do a lot of stunt work in this episode.
但是就像，是的，乔什，当你在这一集中也这么说时，你知道我在想什么，你在这一集中做了很多特技工作。
You take a big fall at one point.
你在某一时刻经历了一次大跌倒。
I get tackled by the police.
我被警察抓住了。
You get tackled by the police.
你会被警察抓住。
You jump a turnstell, get tackled by the police.
你跳过转机，被警察抓住。
It is, there is a lot, you were like an action star in this one.
是的，有很多，你在这方面就像一个动作明星。
The whole episode begins with you running.
整个情节都是从你跑步开始的。
I can't remember if I had a stunt.
我不记得我是否有特技。
I think there was a stunt person.
我认为有一个特技演员。
I can't remember if I did my own stunts or not.
我不记得我是否做过自己的特技。
I mean, I was the Tom Cruise of the set.
我的意思是，我是剧中的汤姆·克鲁斯。
I've mostly waved off the stunt, man, I believe.
我相信我基本上已经放弃了这个噱头。
I think you did because we're on you.
我想你这么做是因为我们在你身上。
We see your face in those stunts and you were really physical and really like, it was great.
我们在那些特技中看到你的脸，你的身体非常好，真的很棒。
I thought that was a very action role for Ted, this one.
我认为这对特德来说是一个非常动作的角色。
I do remember even in reading the draft, Barney has a couple of sex jokes, but the Barney story that he thinks you don't need to train for a marathon, you just run it, is so funny.
我确实记得即使在读选秀时，巴尼也有几个性笑话，但是巴尼的故事非常有趣，他认为你不需要为马拉松训练，你只需跑就可以了。
Okay, so that is a true story Carter either knows the person that did it or heard about it.
好吧，这是一个真实的故事，卡特要么认识做这件事的人，要么听说过这件事。
I haven't heard back, I was trying to remember if it was someone he knew where he was once removed, but this really happened.
我没有收到回音，我试图回忆是否是他认识的人，他曾经被转移到哪里，但这确实发生了。
Somebody was at a bar drinking and said, I could run that marathon tomorrow and did it.
有人在酒吧喝酒时说，我明天可以跑马拉松，然后就这么做了。
And it was rendered basically, did it, like basically this story.
它基本上是渲染出来的，就像这个故事一样。
I can't remember if it ended with that the person like actually being stuck in some way, but I think basically was like unable to walk the next day.
我不记得最后是否会导致这个人实际上被困在某种方式中，但我认为基本上就像第二天无法行走。
It was literally, it was physically incapacitated from having done it.
从字面上看，它在身体上没有能力去做这件事。
And it's just one of those stories that Carter heard that he was just probably in the back of his head, like that's gold, that's gotta go somewhere.
这只是卡特听到的故事之一，他可能只是在他的脑海里，就像那是金子，它一定要去某个地方。
And that's the interesting thing about breaking an episode like this.
这就是打破这样的一集的有趣之处。
You come up with the structure and you say, what's a funny vignette?
你想出了结构，然后你说，什么是有趣的小插曲？
That can, we know exactly the size and shape.
那可以，我们确切地知道尺寸和形状。
It has to be, it has to be this funny little story that can fit exactly right here.
一定是，一定是这个有趣的小故事，非常适合这里。
And somehow it has to drag head into it and make Ted get arrested.
不知怎的，它必须把头拖进去，让特德被捕。
How do we achieve that?
我们如何实现这一目标？
And this was the perfect, the absolute perfect answer to that question.
这就是这个问题的完美、绝对完美的答案。
Neil's Pratt fall when he thinks he can stand up and falls instead of standing on that subway.
尼尔扮演的普拉特以为自己可以站起来，却摔倒了，而不是站在地铁上。
Every time I will see that, I have to rewind it and watch it like three more times because he just so believes he's gonna stand up.
每次我看到这个，我都必须倒带并再看三遍，因为他坚信他会站起来。
Well, the way my memory of it, because I was watching the actual, I was watching, I was there that day, right?
嗯，我的记忆方式，因为我正在观看实际的，我正在观看，那天我就在那里，对吧？
So I'm watching him do it.
所以我就看着他这么做。
And I remember thinking, this is unbelievably good physical comedy.
我记得我当时想，这是一部令人难以置信的精彩肢体喜剧。
Oh my God, but it's such a, it's such a like, the given circumstances, like he ran a marathon with great hubris, he thinks it's already on, he has lost control of his leg.
天哪，但是这就是这样，这就是这样，在给定的情况下，就像他狂妄地跑了一场马拉松一样，他认为比赛已经开始了，他失去了对腿的控制。
It's such a, it's such a, it's such a, it's such a hubris story.
这是这样，这是这样，这是这样，这是一个傲慢的故事。
It's like a Greek myth.
这就像希腊神话一样。
Like it's on, and a marathon, of course, comes from ancient Greece.
就像它一样，马拉松当然来自古希腊。
Yeah, yeah, but that's really funny.
是啊，是啊，但这真的很有趣。
But that is really funny.
但这真的很有趣。
Yeah, but I remember the way it was shot was like, you saw it through the subway window, and you saw him just go down.
是的，但我记得拍摄的方式就像是，你通过地铁窗户看到它，然后你看到他就倒下了。
But I saw him through the door, so I saw his whole body.
但我透过门看到了他，所以我看到了他的整个身体。
And it was even more impressive live than it looks on that.
现场比看起来更令人印象深刻。
Like, him, he just like, I don't know, I just believed he didn't have use of his legs.
就像他，他只是喜欢，我不知道，我只是相信他的腿没有用处。
A ton of, just down like a ton of bricks.
一吨，就像一吨砖头一样。
It's how casual his face is.
可见他的表情是多么的随意。
His face doesn't know that fall is gonna happen.
他的脸不知道跌倒即将发生。
It's just a genius physical form.
这简直就是天才的肉身形态。
Yes, his body is split in two.
是的，他的身体被分成了两半。
his upper body is feeling one thing, and his lower body is not cooperating.
他的上半身感觉到了一件事，而他的下半身却不配合。
It's so fucking funny.
真是太他妈搞笑了
Neil Patrick Harris, ladies and gentlemen, my God, he is just a genius there.
尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯，女士们先生们，天哪，他真是个天才。
He's such a good physical comedian.
他真是一位出色的肢体喜剧演员。
I loved when he said, I've seen where it turns around Ted, you don't ever want to see where the subway turns around.
我喜欢他说的，“我已经看到了地铁在哪里转弯，泰德，你永远不会想看到地铁在哪里转弯。”
Because the subway, if you live in New York City, by the way, we were watching it, he said, 86 on the four and five, I think, right?
因为地铁，如果你住在纽约市，顺便说一句，我们正在看它，他说，86号四号线和五号线，我想，对吧？
Right, like that was her hometown spot.
没错，那是她的家乡。
I mean, that's, she grew up on the Upper East Side, so she.
我的意思是，她是在上东区长大的，所以她。
Oh, and then the four and five no longer stops at those exact stops or something.
哦，然后四号和五号不再停在那些确切的站点或其他地方。
No, I think it does.
不，我认为确实如此。
Maybe he does.
也许他会。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
I thought it was an old tech moment.
我认为这是一个古老的科技时刻。
Or maybe it was the six, but go ahead.
或者也许是六个，但继续吧。
That's just saying that watching how I met your mother, when Barney says he's going to do this, and you see he's doing it, and Marshall is insisting that he's cheating.
这只是说，看看我是如何认识你母亲的，当巴尼说他要这样做时，你看到他正在这样做，而马歇尔坚持认为他在作弊。
Your brain is swirling going, he's clearly, definitely cheating.
你的大脑在旋转，他显然在作弊。
He's definitely cheating.
他绝对是在作弊。
I can't wait to find out your sweetie.
我迫不及待地想找到你的宝贝。
I thought he was cheating.
我以为他在作弊。
And there was almost a disappointment when it wasn't paying off, it wasn't happening, it wasn't happening.
当它没有得到回报、它没有发生、它没有发生时，人们几乎感到失望。
And then it raises the bar of how you have to pay off that story.
然后它提高了你必须如何偿还这个故事的门槛。
And I think we fucking nailed it.
我想我们已经成功了。
Because the dead legs thing is just a thing of beauty.
因为死腿的事情只是一件美丽的事情。
It is just one of my favorite physical comedy moments on the whole series.
这只是整个系列中我最喜欢的肢体喜剧时刻之一。
And again, it's kind of like you gave Barney like you give him this triumph, right?
再说一次，这有点像你给了巴尼就像你给了他胜利一样，对吧？
He gets this triumph, right?
他获得了这次胜利，对吗？
He's like, it's unbelievable.
他就像，这令人难以置信。
He's walking around the city like he owns it, right?
他在这座城市里走来走去，就像他拥有这座城市一样，对吗？
And then you take it away, like you show that like.
然后你把它拿走，就像你表现出来的那样。
Yeah, and it's funny too, because he's also like a real snob about the subway.
是的，这也很有趣，因为他对地铁也像个真正的势利小人。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Even like in a pre-ooper age, he was just, he's riding, he's doing cab, he's doing car services.
即使就像在前工人时代一样，他只是，他在骑车，他在做出租车，他在做汽车服务。
What is the subway I've heard about?
我听说过的地铁是什么？
And the idea that he gets imprisoned, it really is Greek.
他被监禁的想法确实是希腊语。
Like he gets, it's like old Greek mythology.
正如他所理解的，这就像古希腊神话。
Like he gets imprisoned forever in the nether world of the city.
就像他被永远囚禁在城市的幽冥世界一样。
In the underworld, he's the underworld.
在冥界，他就是冥界。
In the underworld, yeah.
在地下世界，是的。
The river sticks.
河水粘住了。
He's doomed to roam the river sticks.
他注定要在河边徘徊。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I like it when the old woman calls him a douche.
我喜欢老妇人叫他混蛋。
That was funny.
这很有趣。
That was a very abrupt douche.
那是一次非常突然的冲洗。
But it was like, it was an old woman, a pregnant woman, and a kid on crutches.
但就像是，这是一个老妇人，一个孕妇，还有一个拄着拐杖的孩子。
Like it just stacks the deck.
就像它只是堆放甲板一样。
Walk into a bar.
走进一家酒吧。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
是的，是的，完全正确。
Fantastic.
极好的。
Robin impersonating the car alarm, and then being driven to a place of madness by the car alarm, a madness and hopelessness.
罗宾冒充汽车警报器，然后被汽车警报器逼到了疯狂的地步，一种疯狂和绝望。
They will never not, they can walk away at any point, by the way.
他们永远不会不这样做，顺便说一句，他们可以随时离开。
Yeah, they can leave at any point, but they don't want to live their place in line.
是的，他们可以随时离开，但他们不想排队。
They don't want to live their place in line.
他们不想排队。
They like Barney.
他们喜欢巴尼。
You can't first can't move their paralyzed by it.
你不能先动不了他们的瘫痪。
And that's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
That really made me laugh when they were singing the song with the car alarm.
当他们用汽车警报器唱这首歌时，这真的让我笑了。
Oh, Robin's trying to make it his game and we'll have fun with it.
哦，罗宾正在努力把它变成他的游戏，我们会玩得很开心的。
Lily starts crying.
莉莉开始哭泣。
That was so alley so funny in that moment.
那一刻那条巷子真是太有趣了。
And the way they fucking hate that guy.
还有他们他妈的讨厌那个家伙。
Oh my guy who shows up beat beat the next morning.
哦，我的家伙第二天早上就出现了。
That's the guy.
就是那个家伙。
He looks like the way you cast him.
他看起来就像你塑造的那样。
He He looks like the guy that turned Barney and Barney.
他他看起来就像是那个改变了巴尼和巴尼的人。
Oh, that would have been such a great callback.
哦，那真是一次很棒的回调。
It should have been that guy.
应该是那个人。
I don't know if it was Robin, or no, it was Lily if we get through this, I'm going to live my life differently.
我不知道是罗宾，还是莉莉，如果我们能渡过难关，我将会以不同的方式过我的生活。
Yeah.
是的。
I just want to tell my parents.
我只想告诉我的父母。
I love them one more time.
我再爱他们一次。
Yeah.
是的。
That is so funny.
那太有趣了。
They can really leave at any point.
他们真的可以随时离开。
It's just a wedding dress, but they just, yeah.
这只是一件婚纱，但它们只是，是的。
Yeah.
是的。
You know what else I thought was a carbo loading is ancient.
你知道我还认为碳水化合物装载是古老的吗？
Like no one recommends carbo loading.
就像没有人建议装载碳一样。
Like eating a plate of linguini before you go running a man his run where he drinks the breakfast and runs and then runs to the bathroom And vomit is like he's still very jonty as he's running Jason's so funny and really good physical comedy in there Jordana asked wait Jordana was like did he really drink that I was like no he didn't really drink it But they must have just given him like a little orange smoothie little orange juice or something maybe at the bottom of that, but he just runs so confidently that you really don't know he's going to vomit.
就像你去跑步之前先吃一盘扁面条，他跑步，他喝完早餐，跑步，然后跑到卫生间，呕吐，因为他在跑步，杰森的身体喜剧非常有趣，非常棒，乔丹娜问等等，乔丹娜说他真的喝了吗，我说不，他没有真正喝，但他们一定只是给了他一点橙子冰沙，一点橙汁，或者可能是在最后的东西，但他跑得那么自信你真的不知道他会呕吐。
So when he's psyching himself up in the mirror when Marshall is, so Jordana said, this is from the Terminator.
所以当他在镜子里给自己打气时，马歇尔也在，乔丹娜说，这是来自《终结者》的。
No, the machine, I'm a machine from the future.
不，是机器，我是来自未来的机器。
Yeah, that's kind of just a little Terminator, a little just Marshall loves robots.
是的，这有点像终结者，有点像马歇尔喜欢机器人。
But it's Terminator meets like we are Marshall, right?
但这是终结者的相遇，就像我们是马歇尔一样，对吧？
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
So it's two movie references jammed into one mirror shot.
所以这是两个电影参考塞进一个镜像镜头中。
And the one from the 80s holds up better than the We Are Marshall one does, right?
80 年代的那张比《我们是马歇尔》的那张更耐用，对吗？
But I was like, right.
但我当时想，对吧。
But I remember that movie was not, it had come out not too long before we were filming this.
但我记得那部电影不是，它是在我们拍摄这个之前不久就上映的。
It was kind of in the air then.
那时空气中弥漫着这样的气氛。
I don't know that it still is.
我不知道现在仍然如此。
It was in the air, but I don't think a lot of people talk about that movie in orbit.
它在空中，但我认为没有多少人在轨道上谈论那部电影。
It was like We Are Marshall was the big champ, right?
就好像我们是马歇尔是大冠军，对吧？
It was.
是的。
I never even saw it, but I know it was a thing and now it doesn't feel like that much of a thing.
我什至从未见过它，但我知道它是一件事，但现在感觉不那么重要了。
But okay, it's a shout out to that movie.
但好吧，这是对那部电影的赞扬。
Yeah, just finally go watch our movie.
是啊，终于去看我们的电影了。
The shot of Marshall rubbing his nipples when Robin walks in is funny.
当罗宾走进来时，马歇尔揉搓乳头的镜头很有趣。
So funny.
太有趣了。
So silly.
太傻了。
There was a lot of falling down in this episode.
这一集有很多跌倒的地方。
You go down at least twice, Ted does.
你至少会摔倒两次，特德就是这样。
Barney a couple of times.
巴尼几次了。
Barney at least won great one.
巴尼至少赢得了一场伟大的胜利。
Marshall's down, at least that one.
马歇尔情绪低落，至少在这一点上是这样。
I do have a stunt note.
我确实有一个特技笔记。
The way that Marshall falls does not look like he would have broken his toe.
从马歇尔摔倒的样子来看，他的脚趾不会骨折。
Right.
正确的。
He broken his fucking back.
他他妈的背断了。
He would have like hurt his like his sacrum or something.
他很想伤害他的骶骨之类的东西。
It was a funny fall, but it didn't look like a toe fall.
这是一次有趣的摔倒，但看起来不像是脚趾摔倒。
It didn't look like a toe fall.
看起来不像是脚趾掉下来的。
Unless, here's what I could, here's what I make, a score.
除非，这就是我能做的，这就是我所做的，一个分数。
He falls and his foot kicks into the toilet.
他摔倒了，脚踢进了厕所。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And with a really high impact.
并且具有非常高的影响力。
That's the only way.
这是唯一的办法。
I broke my toe on a kitchen chair and they're like just walking around the kitchen last summer and that is exactly how it had.
我在厨房的椅子上摔断了脚趾，就像去年夏天在厨房里走来走去一样，事情就是这样。
I just like full force and do a kitchen chair like it can happen.
我只是喜欢全力以赴地做一把厨房椅子，就像它可以发生一样。
Another old ref that I actually like that might be a little more in the air right now, but Lilly makes a reference to Lilith Fair, the line at Lilith Fair in 1998.
另一位我真正喜欢的老裁判现在可能有点悬而未决，但 Lilly 提到了 Lilith Fair，这是 1998 年 Lilith Fair 上的台词。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Which by the way, I don't know if we talked about this, but my wife and I watched that documentary on Lilith Fair, which is fantastic.
顺便说一句，我不知道我们是否讨论过这个问题，但我和我的妻子观看了有关莉莉丝博览会的纪录片，非常棒。
Oh cool.
哦，酷。
And really worth watching.
并且确实值得一看。
Okay, I'll check that out.
好的，我会检查一下。
That was a big deal in the late 90s and came back around, right?
这在 90 年代末是一件大事，后来又卷土重来，对吧？
That's what you're saying.
这就是你所说的。
Well, I don't know if they might have redone it, but they made a documentary about it, which is really terrific.
嗯，我不知道他们是否会重做，但他们制作了一部关于它的纪录片，这真的很棒。
Cool, I'll check that out.
酷，我会检查一下。
Yeah.
是的。
That was a funny reference.
这是一个有趣的参考。
That's a good old rep.
这是一位很好的老代表。
I stand by that one.
我支持这一点。
That one was a little fair.
那个有点公平。
Yeah.
是的。
I thought the woman, both people at the gate, the airport were terrific.
我觉得那个女人、门口的人和机场的人都很棒。
Both funny, again, both really funny.
两者都很有趣，再次，两者都非常有趣。
Come in if you're an actor and just try to kill that part.
如果你是一名演员，请进来并尝试杀死那个角色。
She was very charming and funny and we probably gave her more lines because she just was like, you knew you were in good hands.
她非常迷人又有趣，我们可能给了她更多的台词，因为她就像，你知道你得到了很好的照顾。
You're certainly not taking away lines if someone's that good.
如果有人那么优秀，你当然不会删掉台词。
And the dude, the second guy who also doesn't let them on the plan, he was really funny.
还有那个家伙，第二个也不让他们参与计划的人，他真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
I think Tina Fey, I think it was on Amy Poehler's podcast, but she was talking about like things she loves.
我想是蒂娜·菲，我想是在艾米·波勒的播客上，但她谈论的是她喜欢的事情。
I think we talked about this in season one, but she talks about like, I think she lives in New Jersey or New York somewhere, but there's like a local New York kind of morning show that she's obsessed with.
我想我们在第一季中讨论过这个，但她说，我想她住在新泽西或纽约的某个地方，但她痴迷于纽约当地的早间节目。
Yeah.
是的。
And there are two anchors that she's particularly obsessed with and has had one or both of them come to many premieres of Tina Fey stuff.
她特别迷恋两位主播，并让其中一位或两位参加了蒂娜·菲 (Tina Fey) 作品的许多首映式。
Yeah.
是的。
But there's a very particular personality that's like a morning show person.
但有一种非常特殊的个性，就像早间秀的人。
Yeah.
是的。
That like really gets into it.
那种感觉真的很深入。
And that guy just played that archetype.
那家伙只是扮演了那个原型。
Like, oh my God.
就像，天啊。
Because also the show's on it, like 430 or five.
因为节目也在上面，比如 430 或 5。
Yeah.
是的。
Like he's clearly a morning riser that throws on his like fun and ridiculous.
就好像他显然是一个早起的人，这让他显得有趣又可笑。
There's nothing else to watch.
没有什么可看的了。
Yeah.
是的。
And Robin, the way Robin gets giddy whenever she gets recognized.
还有罗宾，每当她被认出时，罗宾就会头晕目眩。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And she's just, Kobe is very funny.
她只是，科比很有趣。
It's the most anonymous way to be on television.
这是出现在电视上最匿名的方式。
You could ever be on television.
你可能会出现在电视上。
She can never believe it that she's recognized, but it's so, so needy of what's happening.
她永远不敢相信自己被认出来了，但这实在是太需要发生的事情了。
Was there ever anyone that did like a compilation of all the names of Robin's Morning Show?
有人喜欢《罗宾早间秀》所有名字的汇编吗？
Because it was like, wake up New York.
因为这就像，唤醒纽约。
Get up New.
起来新。
Send those to us if anyone has.
如果有人有，请将其发送给我们。
There was a bunch of them.
他们有很多。
Yeah.
是的。
Those are really funny.
这些真的很有趣。
By the way, Crick, shout out to Meredith Scott Lynn.
顺便说一句，克里克，向梅雷迪思·斯科特·林恩大声喊叫。
She's the one that plays.
她就是那个演戏的人。
Oh yes, yes.
哦，是的，是的。
She was terrific.
她太棒了。
Really funny and a delight on set.
现场真的很有趣，很愉快。
Throwing it away, you know, not pushing.
你知道，扔掉它，而不是推动它。
Sometimes people come into those smaller parts and like, try to, this is my one thing I got a nail in.
有时候，人们会进入那些较小的部分，并喜欢尝试，这是我唯一坚持下来的事情。
She was very throwing it all away, very casual, and that was what worked and was funny.
她完全抛弃了一切，非常随意，这就是有效且有趣的方法。
I also thought her faints of like thinking that she was getting around the plane, but it was always talking to her mom.
我还以为她晕倒了，以为自己在飞机上转悠，但飞机总是在和她妈妈说话。
Those were really funny.
那些真的很有趣。
I also really liked Kobe's trying to walk back, like surely you didn't dream of being, you know, and then having to kind of walk, but your outfit's really pretty.
我也很喜欢科比试图走回来，就像你肯定没有梦想过那样，你知道，然后不得不走，但你的衣服真的很漂亮。
Yeah, Kobe was always, I was just about to say, Kobe was always really funny when she stepped in it.
是的，科比总是，我正想说，科比介入的时候总是很有趣。
And then it's like, it literally remember when she stepped in it.
然后就像，它真的记得她什么时候踩进去的。
Like in, in season, you literally have it.
就像在季节里一样，你确实拥有它。
Yeah.
是的。
I, again, another like little improvisation, these are so small, but because they were so little room for improvisation, but when, when Kobe and I were walking with the hot dog that, that the Lucky Penny paid for.
我，再次，另一个喜欢即兴创作的东西，这些很小，但因为它们的即兴创作空间很小，但是当科比和我带着热狗散步时，幸运便士付了钱。
Yeah.
是的。
And she says something like in however many years, maybe we'll get like 30 years, we'll be able to get another hot dog or something.
她说不管多少年后，也许我们会花30年，我们就能再吃到一个热狗之类的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I said, how dare you, but I don't think that was in the script.
我说，你怎么敢，但我认为剧本里没有这样的内容。
I think that was just like something I either said.
我认为这就像我所说的那样。
And she laughed in a very natural way because it wasn't in the script.
她笑得很自然，因为剧本里没有。
And it's funny, you can spot those moments, those little moments where you can see her being surprised by it.
有趣的是，你可以发现那些时刻，那些你可以看到她对此感到惊讶的小时刻。
It was very charming, it was very cute, the two of you.
你们两个非常迷人，非常可爱。
It's a good Ted and Robin in it together episode, even though you are kind of going, well, wait a second, what if he goes to Chicago and somehow he gets to, like there's a little bit of a sign of what would happen if he had to move to Chicago?
泰德和罗宾在一起的情节很好，尽管你有点想，好吧，等一下，如果他去芝加哥并且以某种方式到达，就像有一点迹象表明如果他必须搬到芝加哥会发生什么？
I know the stakes of this are not, he's gonna move to Chicago.
我知道这并不重要，他要搬到芝加哥。
He's gonna Chicago to get a job in New York.
他要去芝加哥去纽约找工作。
Well, you don't realize it.
好吧，你没有意识到这一点。
Like, I thought that he was, maybe I missed the line.
就像，我以为他是，也许我错过了线路。
I think maybe Narrator Ted says, I was interviewing with a Chicago firm to be in New York, to stay in New York.
我想也许旁白特德说，我正在面试一家芝加哥公司，要去纽约，留在纽约。
Stay come back to New York.
留下来回到纽约。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And run their New York office, right?
并管理他们的纽约办事处，对吧？
Right, yes.
对，是的。
Those were the stakes and it was spelled out.
这些就是赌注，而且已经明确了。
We didn't really, like I like the Ted that Robin was gonna go with him.
我们并不是真的，就像我喜欢罗宾要和他一起去的泰德一样。
I know.
我知道。
I like that too.
我也喜欢这样。
So they almost felt like we should have made more of that.
所以他们几乎觉得我们应该做得更多。
Like that's a big step forward in their relationship.
这就像他们的关系向前迈出了一大步。
They've probably never gone away for a little two-day trip to anywhere.
他们可能从来没有去任何地方进行过为期两天的小旅行。
And we kind of skipped over that, but I liked it anyway.
我们有点跳过了，但我还是喜欢它。
I liked the energy of it.
我喜欢它的能量。
It shows you that their relationship is escalating.
这表明他们的关系正在升级。
I liked that she was as desperate to get on the plane as he was.
我喜欢她和他一样渴望登上飞机。
She wanted her.
她想要她。
She had taken on the urgency of my fella needs to get to Chicago, and it was in a meta lot to her.
她已经接受了我朋友去芝加哥的紧迫需求，这对她来说是一个重要的事情。
Yeah, because she relates, she's ambitious.
是的，因为她相关，她雄心勃勃。
And she's like, this is a great opportunity for Daddy's killing it, and he's being headhunted, which also is cool, it's cool.
她说，这是爸爸杀死它的好机会，他正在被猎头，这也很酷，很酷。
Again, I forgot in this season how much Ted's career is kind of in the air of this season.
再次，我忘记了本赛季特德的职业生涯有多少悬念。
Like Ted's architect career is very present.
就像 Ted 的建筑师职业生涯是非常现实的。
Even in this episode, everything is being driven by that.
即使在这一集中，一切都是由此驱动的。
I forgot how true that was of this season.
我忘记了这一季的真实情况。
I like it, I like that it's another speed, because Ted's not out dating, he's with Robin.
我喜欢它，我喜欢这是另一种速度，因为泰德没有出去约会，他和罗宾在一起。
So we need other shit for Ted while it's career.
因此，在泰德的职业生涯中，我们需要其他的东西。
Yeah, when they were running to the gate, I said to my wife, I said, This is how you're supposed to arrive at the airport.
是的，当他们跑到登机口时，我对我的妻子说，这就是你到达机场的方式。
And this was not good for her to hear.
而且这话让她听不太好。
I mean, as a joke, just because she is a, and I think this is our olive theory.
我的意思是，作为一个笑话，仅仅因为她是一个，我认为这是我们的橄榄理论。
This is me and my wife's olive theory.
这是我和我妻子的橄榄理论。
I want to be at the gate for no time.
我不想在门口待太久。
I want to walk through security.
我想通过安检。
I want to walk out to the plane.
我想步行去飞机。
So I sometimes go to the airport too late.
所以有时我去机场太晚了。
I'm Jordana in this one.
我是乔丹娜。
I cannot do that.
我不能那样做。
She wants to get there four hours early.
她想提前四个小时到达那里。
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
And sit and wait at the gate, which I think is absurd, but we're still married.
然后坐在门口等待，我认为这很荒谬，但我们仍然是夫妻。
How often do you miss glitz though?
但你有多少次怀念浮华呢？
We've only missed one, but I'll tell you why, because I had a thing that she came to me with in Canada.
我们只错过了一个，但我会告诉你原因，因为她在加拿大给我带来了一件东西。
I performed at a benefit in Canada, and she, we didn't realize that the Canadian cutoff was different, like the, it was different than America.
我在加拿大的一次慈善活动中表演，而她，我们没有意识到加拿大的截止标准是不同的，就像，它与美国不同。
I was like Thanksgiving, it's earlier.
我就像感恩节，它更早。
It was an early flight, But here's the, this is our lucky penny.
这是一个早班飞机，但是这是，这是我们的幸运便士。
I wonder if she's listening to this right now and laughing, she's probably gonna burst in and say, no, that was wrong.
我想知道她现在是否正在听这个并大笑，她可能会突然插嘴说，不，那是错误的。
She doesn't sound like that.
她听起来不像那样。
Is she texting me?
她在给我发短信吗？
No, she's not watching the text.
不，她没有看短信。
But in the morning, when we were leaving the hotel, she stopped, she said, wait, I just wanna grab a coffee.
但早上，当我们离开酒店时，她停了下来，她说，等等，我只是想喝杯咖啡。
Like they had coffee out.
就像他们出去喝咖啡一样。
So she grabbed a coffee.
于是她喝了一杯咖啡。
She is listening.
她正在听。
Josh, she's listening.
乔希，她在听。
As you talk to him right now.
当你现在和他说话时。
I'll cap them listening.
我会让他们听的。
So watch your words right now.
所以现在要注意你的言语。
So she gets a cup of coffee and then we go to the airport.
所以她喝了一杯咖啡，然后我们去机场。
Oh, please, Josh, I'm gonna get her reactions in real time.
哦，拜托，乔什，我会实时得到她的反应。
We missed the flight by literally like, it was like 45 seconds.
我们错过了航班，大约 45 秒。
Like it had just closed and it was one of those things like we can't override the baggage cut off or whatever it was.
就像它刚刚关闭一样，这是我们无法超越行李切断或其他任何东西的事情之一。
That's hilarious.
太搞笑了。
And I have always said, well, if you didn't stop to get that cup of coffee, this is like two years ago, by the way.
我总是说，好吧，如果你没有停下来喝杯咖啡，顺便说一句，这就像两年前一样。
You know, this is madness.
你知道，这太疯狂了。
You know, you're just looking for trouble here.
你知道，你只是在这里自找麻烦。
This is longer than two years ago.
这比两年前还要长。
But yes, but this has been a running argument.
但是，是的，但这一直是一个争论不休的话题。
You lived a lucky penny.
你过着幸运的生活。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
Yeah, that's really funny.
是的，这真的很有趣。
But then we, there was another flight like 90 minutes later that we got on, so we just ended up having breakfast and it ended up to be a fine morning and we got to back back to New York.
但后来我们，大约 90 分钟后，还有另一趟航班，我们就上了，所以我们就吃完早餐，结果是一个美好的早晨，我们就回到了纽约。
I'm just trying to see if Jordana is weighing in and saying, Oh fuck you.
我只是想看看乔丹娜是否会介入并说，哦操你。
Yeah, see what Jordana would like to say, but now he comes to the airport early with me.
是啊，看看乔丹娜想说什么，但现在他和我一起提前到机场了。
And enjoy the truth.
并享受真理。
All the truth, all counts.
一切真相，一切都很重要。
She changed you.
她改变了你。
You're a changed man.
你是一个变了的人。
Shaming me.
羞辱我。
She's helped you evolve.
她帮助你成长。
That's what I mean.
这就是我的意思。
No, you guys, yeah, tell the truth.
不，你们，是的，说实话。
Oh, please, Josh, she says, I can't.
哦，拜托，乔希，她说，我不能。
She is listening to me.
她正在听我说话。
We're gonna paint the picture.
我们要画这幅画。
She is in another room listening to this and texting.
她在另一个房间里听着这个并发短信。
She has it off on the computer in the background.
她在后台将其关闭。
This is really true.
这确实是真的。
She likes listening sometimes when you're recording, so she's texting in some clarifications.
她有时喜欢在你录音时听，所以她会发短信进行一些澄清。
Yeah, it's like shaming and clarifications from a clinical psychologist, who's never seen how I met Your mother also happens to be married to children.
是的，这就像一位临床心理学家的羞辱和澄清，他从未见过我是如何认识你的母亲也恰好结婚了孩子。
Hello, Al.
你好，艾尔。
She's enjoying this.
她很享受这个。
I really like the work.
我真的很喜欢这份工作。
This is now a podcast where we just get texts from the other ones.
现在这是一个播客，我们只是从其他播客那里获取文本。
And this old man.
还有这个老人。
He musted me.
他必须我。
Fell in love with you.
爱上你了。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
like, I'm 30, and I'm scared to drive in New York.
就像，我 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car-related problems.
我们还解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials?
广告完结了？
Back to show.
返回展示。
By the way, we have text coming in hot.
顺便说一句，我们有热门文字。
I'm texting with Carter now.
我现在正在给卡特发短信。
Okay, here's a clarification and unaware of the Barney story from Carter is texting me.
好吧，这是一个澄清，我不知道卡特正在给我发短信，讲述巴尼的故事。
I said, wait, did you know the guy that had happened to?
我说，等等，你认识发生这种事的那个人吗？
And he says, LOL, I think I heard that story on a date.
他说，哈哈，我想我在约会时听到了这个故事。
No idea how true it is, but as soon as I heard it, I knew we'd be using it on the show.
不知道它的真实性如何，但我一听到它，我就知道我们会在节目中使用它。
So, okay, we can't, I take it back.
所以，好吧，我们不能，我收回那句话。
We don't know for sure that a guy did it, but he didn't hear from a date that it happened.
我们不确定是某个人干的，但他没有从约会中听说这件事发生过。
Well, you know, it's funny.
嗯，你知道，这很有趣。
So somewhere out there, there's a guy who ran a marathon and lost the usage legs, right?
那么，在某个地方，有一个人跑了马拉松，却失去了双腿的使用能力，对吗？
For a time.
一时间。
Okay.
好的。
With the hubris of I can run the marathon without training.
凭借傲慢，我可以在没有训练的情况下跑马拉松。
That part is, here's what happened to me constantly.
这部分是，这就是我经常发生的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
When you guys started taking stuff from my life and making it Ted.
当你们开始从我的生活中拿走一些东西并将其变成特德时。
Yeah.
是的。
So that guy is out there telling this story.
所以那个人正在外面讲这个故事。
Like, this is the craziest story that ever happened to me.
就像，这是我经历过的最疯狂的故事。
I decided I could run a marathon.
我决定我可以跑马拉松。
I ran it, I finished it, and then I lost the use of my legs.
我跑了它，我完成了它，然后我的腿就失去了作用。
People were like, Oh my God, just like how I met your boss.
人们说，天啊，就像我遇见你老板一样。
And he's like, No, that's my story.
他说，不，这是我的故事。
That was my story.
这就是我的故事。
Faith, you're right about that.
信仰，你是对的。
Yeah, you're right about that.
是的，你是对的。
You know?
你知道？
It's really weird.
真的很奇怪。
All these things.
所有这些事情。
Now they've been in the pop culture for 19, 20 years.
现在它们已经进入流行文化 19、20 年了。
And Carter says, and yes, in the story, this guy was stuck sitting on the subway for hours.
卡特说，是的，在故事中，这个人被困在地铁上几个小时。
So that subway part was part of it.
所以地铁部分是其中的一部分。
Okay.
好的。
I mean, it's funny that like the truest stuff is the best stuff.
我的意思是，有趣的是，最真实的东西就是最好的东西。
And it often seems like the most far-fetched.
这往往看起来是最牵强的。
It is like truth is stranger than fiction.
就像事实比小说更奇怪一样。
Like if you had to choose a part of this episode that happened, the one real part of this whole episode, when you have said the guy that ran the marathon and got stuck on the subway.
就像如果你必须选择这一集发生的一部分，整个集的一个真实部分，当你说那个跑马拉松并被困在地铁里的人时。
No, you'd be like the 1939 penny.
不，你会像 1939 年的便士一样。
Right, any other part would make a true part.
是的，任何其他部分都可以成为真正的部分。
And I don't think there's one other true part besides that story, which again, I hope is true from some date Carter and 25 years ago.
我不认为除了这个故事之外还有其他真实的部分，我再次希望卡特和 25 年前的某个日期的故事是真实的。
It's incredible.
太不可思议了。
But it also shows that Carter has an appropriately sticky writer mind, which is like, if you're a writer, you have a file in your head that is like a great title, great scenario, great character, tick, like they're always going in.
但这也表明卡特有一个适当的粘性作家头脑，就像，如果你是一名作家，你脑子里有一个文件，就像一个伟大的标题，伟大的场景，伟大的角色，勾选，就像他们总是会进去一样。
And when you find the right place for them, It's delightful.
当你为他们找到合适的地方时，那就令人高兴了。
I think the idea that there was some special wedding dress sale was like that that exists.
我认为举办一些特别的婚纱促销活动的想法是存在的。
Someone had a story like that, but it wasn't exactly like, there was a few like little kernels of truth in here, but the realest thing was the thing that seems the most absolutely made up.
有人有一个这样的故事，但并不完全一样，这里有一些类似的小真相，但最真实的东西似乎是最绝对编造的。
Well, this is a great example of a, I guess I wonder if I would love to find like a name for these kinds of episodes.
嗯，这是一个很好的例子，我想我想知道我是否愿意为这类剧集找到一个名字。
Like I always call it like, this isn't quite that, but like filling in the lore episodes, kind of like how I met everyone else is a great filling in the lore, you know, even showing like how Barney became, I really like how you guys run with Barney as a gambling addiction.
就像我总是这样称呼它，这并不完全是那样，但就像填充传说情节一样，有点像我如何遇见其他人是对传说的一个很好的填充，你知道，甚至表现出巴尼的样子，我真的很喜欢你们如何与巴尼一起作为赌博成瘾。
Like once you got that, it was like a very reliable well to draw.
就像一旦你得到了它，它就像一口非常可靠的井一样可以抽水。
His turns on, okay, 50 bucks, he's so good at that.
他的动作很快，好吧，50 美元，他太擅长了。
In the X-Files world, there's the mythology versus the monster of the week episodes.
在《X 档案》世界中，有神话对抗本周怪物的剧集。
You have very few monster of the week episodes, even if the network and studio wanted more of those and more mythology.
本周的怪物剧集很少，即使网络和工作室想要更多这样的怪物和更多的神话。
That's right, that's right.
没错，没错。
And we just, and I'm like, I've said this on here before, I'm very proud of Carter and I that we just, we stuck with the mythology piece more than the can, the box of candies.
我们只是，我之前说过，我为卡特和我感到非常自豪，我们只是，我们比罐头，一盒糖果更坚持神话。
You know, I would argue that like Monster of the Week, I understand why networks would demand them because they're trying to get people who just stumble across it and can watch a self-contained episode for 22 minutes or 48 minutes or whatever.
你知道，我想说，就像《本周怪物》一样，我理解为什么网络会要求它们，因为他们试图让那些偶然发现它并且可以观看 22 分钟或 48 分钟或其他独立剧集的人。
But if you want to create a show that lasts that people are watching 20 years later, it's got to have mythology.
但如果你想创作一部能让人们在 20 年后继续观看的节目，它就必须有神话色彩。
Like I don't think any show that people still talk about a decade after it went off the air, I think it has to have mythology to it.
就像我不认为有任何节目在停播十年后人们还在谈论一样，我认为它必须有神话色彩。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
But I love that this episode has a mythology piece and I also love that it is the best of both worlds.
但我喜欢这一集有一个神话片段，我也喜欢它是两全其美的。
It is everybody's on one thing.
这是每个人都在做一件事。
Everybody's on this one through line and is there kind of all on the same train track to steal the part of the train metaphor of the episode itself?
每个人都在这条直通线上，是否所有人都在同一条火车轨道上窃取了剧集本身的火车隐喻部分？
They're all kind of together, but each person also has their own little vignette that's very much their own thing.
他们都在一起，但每个人也有自己的小插曲，这是他们自己的事情。
It is a great balance of two things where everybody has a thing and they're also all in the same thing at the same time.
这是两件事的完美平衡，每个人都有自己的一件事，同时他们也都在同一件事上。
It's the best of both worlds.
这是两全其美的。
But it also all arises out of their character.
但这也都源于他们的性格。
Like Barney's plot line arises out of his hubris and Ted's plot line arises out of his love of old things.
就像巴尼的情节源于他的傲慢，而泰德的情节源于他对旧事物的热爱。
And Lilly is, I mean, she has very expensive tastes very expensive tastes and she has a kindergartners teaching salary, like she's trying to navigate.
我的意思是，莉莉的品味非常昂贵，她的薪水相当于幼儿园教师的工资，就像她正在努力导航一样。
And they're getting married.
他们要结婚了。
It keeps alive their wedding.
这让他们的婚礼保持活力。
And they're getting married in Marshall's in law school and presumably taking out loans.
他们将在马歇尔法学院结婚，并且可能会申请贷款。
She's really trying to navigate how to make her way through that.
她确实在努力寻找如何渡过难关的方法。
It all comes from characters.
这一切都来自角色。
So even Marshall's getting married.
所以连马歇尔也要结婚了。
He doesn't want to have a tummy.
他不想有肚子。
He doesn't want to be an old, like, doughy married guy.
他不想成为一个又老又软的已婚男人。
He's like, no, I have to change my body around.
他说，不，我必须改变我的身体。
Like, all of it comes from, yeah, comes from character.
就像，所有这些都来自，是的，来自性格。
And this also, this is the kind of episode where you have to have 35 episodes under your belt to do this kind of episode.
而且，这种剧集需要你有 35 集才能完成。
Like, you could not do this in the opening 12 episodes, like you just don't know enough about the characters and you're not invested enough.
就像，你不能在前 12 集里做到这一点，就像你对角色不够了解，而且你没有足够的投入。
So I think this is like, this to me was an episode where it was like season two was like all guns firing.
所以我认为这对我来说就像是第二季的一集就像所有枪声一样。
Like, this feels like a really, really good example of what the show was at its best and where it was headed and what it did differently than any other show on the air at the time.
就像，这感觉就像一个非常非常好的例子，展示了该节目的最佳状态、它的发展方向以及它与当时正在播出的任何其他节目的不同之处。
Yeah, and this one holds up really well.
是的，而且这个效果非常好。
I'm really proud of this one.
我真的为这个感到自豪。
And yeah, it's a great TED episode too.
是的，这也是一个很棒的 TED 剧集。
It's all driven by TED's career.
这一切都是由 TED 的职业生涯推动的。
There's this action movie, suspenseful thing happening in the present, Robin and Ted are very much together.
有一部动作电影，悬疑的事情发生在当下，罗宾和泰德非常在一起。
It escalates their relationship.
这使他们的关系升级。
It keeps the live Marshall and the other game married.
它让现场的马歇尔和其他游戏保持结合。
There's so many boxes, this is jacking and little subtle ones too.
有这么多盒子，这是千斤顶，还有一些微妙的盒子。
It really, yeah.
确实如此，是的。
You know, I came up with a big idea for something and I was talking to a friend of mine who has such a wild imagination, like such a good imagination.
你知道，我想出了一个伟大的想法，当时我正在和我的一个朋友交谈，他的想象力非常丰富，非常丰富。
We were talking about maybe collaborating on this thing, but he doesn't think dramatically or dramaturgically, he thinks just in these big, beautiful kind of images and themes.
我们正在谈论也许在这件事上进行合作，但他并没有戏剧性或戏剧性地思考，他只是在这些大而美丽的图像和主题中思考。
And I was just trying to explain him the basics of drama, which is like the characters all have to want something, something has to be in the way of them getting what they want and they have to adjust their behavior to get what they want.
我只是想向他解释戏剧的基础知识，就像所有角色都必须想要某些东西，某些东西必须妨碍他们得到他们想要的东西，他们必须调整自己的行为才能得到他们想要的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
And you see, like, from the get-go, it's like Ted and Ron got to get on this plane.
你看，从一开始，泰德和罗恩就必须登上这架飞机。
Why has this job interview and he thinks it's his destiny?
为什么要接受这次工作面试，而他认为这是他的命运？
They're late.
他们迟到了。
Why are they late?
他们为什么迟到？
Okay.
好的。
So what do they do?
那么他们做什么呢？
How do they talk to these gate, these literal gatekeepers?
他们如何与这些大门、这些真正的看门人交谈？
You know, like, how do they try, how do this is their behavior adapt and change?
你知道，比如，他们如何尝试，他们的行为如何适应和改变？
Like, you could really, you really can map out the wants and the obstacles.
就像，你真的可以，你真的可以规划出需求和障碍。
It's very Greek mythology.
这是非常希腊神话。
It's a very Greek mythology down to there being a marathon and a medal, Barney's stripped of his medal at the end.
这是一个非常希腊神话，其中有一场马拉松和一枚奖牌，巴尼最后被剥夺了他的奖牌。
Like there's a prize, the prize has taken away.
就像有奖品一样，奖品已经被拿走了。
The gatekeeper, their gatekeepers.
看门人，他们的看门人。
It is very like Greek, ancient Greek drama shit.
这很像希腊、古希腊戏剧。
And it's also about like transportation and trying to get places that you can't get to.
它还涉及交通和试图到达你无法到达的地方。
Yeah.
是的。
It always feels like a dream.
总感觉像做梦一样。
Like the mythology of like, don't see where the subway turns around.
就像神话里的一样，看不到地铁在哪里转弯。
And Barney's stuck in a purgatory.
巴尼被困在炼狱里。
Like there's a lot, there's a lot of like ancient drama happening in this.
就像有很多，有很多像古代戏剧一样的事情发生在这里面。
I want to give one other shout out, which is, we don't say this enough, our production team for this episode, like the set design, just everything about this episode, that airport was huge.
我想大声疾呼，也就是说，我们说得还不够，我们这一集的制作团队，比如布景设计，关于这一集的一切，那个机场很大。
That has to be that heat up half of stage 22 when we built, because you guys are making left turns and running down a hallway and like, that's an enormous feat to make a set where you can actually run through the set.
当我们建造时，这一定是第 22 赛段的一半热度，因为你们要左转并沿着走廊奔跑，这是一项巨大的壮举，要制作一个可以真正跑过整个场景的场景。
I'm sure we had to do things like have that big line of smart cards block you, because we would have run out of set otherwise, like we need to slow Ted and Robin down.
我确信我们必须做一些事情，比如让那一大排智能卡阻止你，因为否则我们就会用完设置，就像我们需要放慢特德和罗宾的速度一样。
But like those tracking shots through that means that was a huge fucking set.
但就像那些跟踪镜头一样，这意味着那是一个巨大的场景。
Then it's like, and this is how amazing our production team is, build us that big of a set that we can have action, you know, a chase scene through an airport.
然后，这就是我们的制作团队是多么令人惊奇，为我们建造了一个大的场景，我们可以有动作，你知道，通过机场的追逐场景。
And then by the way, the next day we need a subway car.
顺便说一下，第二天我们需要地铁车厢。
This might have been one where we used stage 21.
这可能是我们使用第 21 阶段的地方。
This might have been one where they get one car with the subway car.
这可能是他们与地铁车厢合用一辆车的情况。
It's coming back to me right now.
现在它又回到我身边了。
Every now and again, we'd be so ambitious.
时不时地，我们会如此雄心勃勃。
We'd have to like use part of the adjacent, the next sound stage over, which luckily was often like more of an influx.
我们必须喜欢使用相邻的下一个声场的一部分，幸运的是，这通常更像是涌入。
It wasn't always a long running show there.
那里的演出并不总是很长时间。
so we could like ask for help and get extra space.
所以我们可以寻求帮助并获得额外的空间。
Just a huge shout out to Susie Greenberg, Steve Olson, the whole production team was amazing in this episode.
向苏西·格林伯格、史蒂夫·奥尔森致敬，整个制作团队在这一集中都表现得非常出色。
Like think about how much is happening in terms of setting.
就像想想设置方面发生了多少事情。
And I want to stress that we would leave on like a Wednesday after shooting or leave after Tuesday.
我想强调的是，我们会在拍摄后的周三离开，或者在周二之后离开。
Nine o'clock, 10 o'clock at night, yeah.
晚上九点，十点，是的。
And you'd come back the next morning and there'd be an airport.
第二天早上你回来时就会有一个机场。
Yeah.
是的。
Here's an entire airport.
这是整个机场。
with multiple locations, like it was so, it was such weird magic that these sets would come up and go away so quickly.
在多个地点，就像这样，这些布景会如此迅速地出现和消失，这真是太奇怪了。
Yeah, amazing.
是的，太棒了。
So that's a huge part of what was special about our show.
所以这是我们节目特别之处的一个重要部分。
All right, we're winding things down here for today, but we're going to end this episode as we end almost all episodes, which is we're gonna read a letter that we received from a fan of the show and a fan of the podcast.
好吧，今天的事情就到此为止了，但是我们将像结束几乎所有剧集一样结束这一集，也就是说，我们将阅读一封来自该剧粉丝和播客粉丝的来信。
If you would like to let us know what how I met your mother means to you, why you watch it over and over again, why you're loving this podcast, watching it with us all over again.
如果您想让我们知道我如何认识您母亲对您意味着什么，为什么您一遍又一遍地观看它，为什么您喜欢这个播客，与我们一起一遍遍地观看它。
Yeah, let us know what how I met your mother means to you, just go to how we madeyourmother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com and go to contact and should be pretty self-explanatory.
是的，让我们知道我如何认识你母亲对你意味着什么，只需访问我们如何制作yourmother.com、h-w-m-y-m.com 并联系我们，这应该是不言自明的。
Leave us a voice note, leave us a written letter.
给我们留言，给我们写信。
We love to, it's one of our favorite things is to hear from people who've loved the show for many years or even people who've just now discovering it.
我们喜欢，我们最喜欢的事情之一就是听到多年来喜欢这个节目的人们甚至是刚刚发现它的人们的来信。
Craig, anything to add?
克雷格，有什么要补充的吗？
No, I just said it's my favorite part of the whole thing of doing this podcast.
不，我只是说这是整个播客中我最喜欢的部分。
Yeah, it's great.
是的，太棒了。
So please, let's dive in.
那么，请让我们深入了解一下。
Let's hear a cool letter from a quote.
让我们听听来自引文中的一封很酷的信。
Okay, well, our letter today is from Julia and she writes, Dear Josh and Craig, first, I'd like to congratulate you both on such a lovely first season of the podcast.
好吧，今天我们的信来自朱莉娅，她写道，亲爱的乔什和克雷格，首先，我要祝贺你们俩的播客第一季如此精彩。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I really admire how you both speak with such wisdom and clarity and have been fascinated by backstories on the production of the show.
我真的很钦佩你们俩说话如此智慧和清晰，并且对节目制作的背景故事着迷。
My love for Hymmium began in middle school.
我对 Hymmium 的喜爱始于中学时期。
Like most younger siblings, I stole many personality aspects from my older brothers, music taste, books, TV shows, and most importantly, Hymmium.
和大多数弟弟妹妹一样，我从哥哥那里学到了很多个性、音乐品味、书籍、电视节目，最重要的是 Hymmium。
I used to watch the show with them after school on our couch, not understanding most jokes or being able to relate to most plots, but still enjoying the show as I got to spend time and laugh with them.
我过去常常放学后在沙发上和他们一起看节目，无法理解大多数笑话或无法理解大多数情节，但仍然很享受这个节目，因为我必须花时间和他们一起欢笑。
As I got older, I found myself re-watching the show and saw it in such a different way, having had more experiences and knowledge life and relationships.
随着年龄的增长，我发现自己重新观看这部剧，并以不同的方式看待它，获得了更多的经验和知识，生活和人际关系。
My family to this day makes fun of me for monopolizing the TV because it plays on a continuous loop in my household most months.
直到今天，我的家人还嘲笑我垄断了电视，因为它在我家里大多数时候都在连续循环播放。
I'm watching it right now as I am writing this.
当我写这篇文章时，我正在看它。
Marshall just got slapped by Barney.
马歇尔刚刚被巴尼打了一巴掌。
Something that has really stuck with me all these years beyond the clever jokes, wise guidance and intricate comedy bits are the music soundtracks played throughout the seasons.
这些年来，除了巧妙的笑话、明智的指导和错综复杂的喜剧片段之外，真正让我印象深刻的是整季播放的音乐配乐。
From block party to the shins, band of horses, gold spot, Fort Atlantic and so many more.
从街区派对到小腿、马乐队、金点、大西洋堡等等。
I've collected the songs into my playlist to listen and grown to favorite them so much.
我把这些歌曲收集到我的播放列表中来听，并且越来越喜欢它们。
This past summer I started dating my boyfriend and we immediately bonded over two things.
去年夏天，我开始和男朋友约会，我们立即因为两件事而建立了联系。
Music, concerts, and how I met your mother.
音乐、音乐会，以及我是如何认识你母亲的。
Naturally our third date was seeing Josh perform on his tour in Pennsylvania.
当然，我们的第三次约会是看乔什在宾夕法尼亚州的巡演中表演。
Unbelievable.
难以置信。
It was such a surreal and fun experience hearing him play in person.
聆听他亲自演奏真是一种超现实且有趣的体验。
And we had the delight of being at one of the special shows where a couple got engaged on the stage.
我们很高兴参加了一场特别演出，一对情侣在舞台上订婚了。
I think we talked about that on the podcast, right?
我想我们在播客上讨论过这个，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
That was a really fun, amazing night.
那真是一个非常有趣、美妙的夜晚。
Yeah.
是的。
Funnily enough, my boyfriend was in New York City with his family just a few weeks later and ran into NPH at a theater.
有趣的是，几周后，我的男朋友和家人来到纽约，在一家剧院遇到了 NPH。
He immediately called me after his tell me how excited he was at the surprise meet.
当他告诉我他对这次惊喜见面感到多么兴奋后，他立即打电话给我。
As our relationship progressed.
随着我们关系的进展。
We've continued to reference him too often.
我们仍然经常提到他。
I always eat his olives and watch it together most nights.
大多数晚上我总是吃他的橄榄并一起看。
We always dread the Mondays.
我们总是害怕星期一。
I have to drive him to the train station after a weekend together.
一起度过一个周末后我必须开车送他去火车站。
But listening to this podcast on my drive home always cheers me up and gives me something to look forward to every week.
但在开车回家的路上听这个播客总是让我振作起来，让我每周都有一些期待。
Additionally, every time we listen to music together and one of the songs from the show comes on, I quiz him on what episode the song played during.
此外，每次我们一起听音乐并且节目中的一首歌曲出现时，我都会询问他这首歌在哪一集播放。
I crush him every time.
我每次都碾压他
Beyond entertainment and guiding my modern love story, himium has continued to teach me countless lessons over the years and reminds me that I still have so much time to find myself in this big world.
除了娱乐和指导我的现代爱情故事之外，hiium 多年来继续教给我无数的教训，并提醒我，我还有很多时间在这个大世界中找到自己。
I recently celebrated my 24th birthday and it feels comforting knowing that the characters in season one are 27 and only just beginning to figure out their life goals and plans.
我最近庆祝了 24 岁生日，知道第一季中的角色已经 27 岁，而且才刚刚开始弄清楚他们的人生目标和计划，这让我感到很欣慰。
Thank you so much, Craig and Josh, for making my most beloved TV show that has shaped my growing up and continues to be a guide post in my adult life.
非常感谢克雷格和乔什制作了我最喜爱的电视节目，它塑造了我的成长，并继续成为我成年生活的指南。
I continue to eagerly listen to the podcast episodes each Monday, and I am most looking forward to in a few years for you to discuss the controversial finale episode.
我每周一都会继续热切地收听播客剧集，我最期待几年后您讨论有争议的结局剧集。
I don't know what she's talking about.
我不知道她在说什么。
And hearing your thoughts on that storyline, personally, I really liked the ending.
听到你对这个故事情节的想法，就我个人而言，我真的很喜欢这个结局。
Thanks, Julia.
谢谢，朱莉娅。
If you end up reading this on the show, just know there's a girl smiling like crazy listening to this right now in her car.
如果你最终在节目中读到了这篇文章，你就知道有一个女孩正在她的车里疯狂地微笑着听着这篇文章。
All the best in admiration, Julia.
祝您一切顺利，朱莉娅。
I love everything about that letter.
我喜欢那封信的一切。
Thank you, Julia.
谢谢你，朱莉娅。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
And I'm so glad we can keep you company on your drive as you part ways from your boyfriend.
我很高兴在您与男友分道扬镳时，我们能在您开车时陪伴您。
But I'm glad you guys have the show to share together.
但我很高兴你们能一起分享这个节目。
I love when I think it's a great show for couples to watch together.
当我认为这是一部适合情侣一起观看的精彩节目时，我很喜欢。
I agree.
我同意。
And I also, I love that there's kind of like, there are these, how I met your mother years, 27 to 36, where it's funny when people are in their 20s and they say, I'm 24.
我也喜欢这样的事情，我是如何在 27 岁到 36 岁之间认识你母亲的，当人们在 20 多岁的时候，他们说，我 24 岁，这很有趣。
I'm so old.
我这么老了。
You know, and you're like, you're like, yeah, your life hasn't started yet.
你知道，你就像，你就像，是的，你的生活还没有开始。
You're not even 27.
你还不到27岁。
So anyway, thanks for that letter, and thanks for all the letters and delighted to spend some time with you all, and we'll see you next time.
不管怎样，感谢你的来信，感谢所有的来信，很高兴能与大家共度时光，我们下次再见。
Thanks so much.
非常感谢。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matata。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajormother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajormother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作。
That's not how it happened, wherever books are sold.
无论在哪里卖书，事情都不是这样发生的。
And check out his other published writings at CraigThomasRider.com.
并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上查看他发表的其他著作。
And you can subscribe to my own dead father's society, also on Substack.
你也可以订阅我已故父亲的社团，也在 Substack 上。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。